l'astra zeneca responsable de cas de
thrombose l'agencé européenne des
médicaments doit statuer sur le vaccin
britanno suédois dans les prochaines
heures
une décision attendue dans un contexte
de polémique au sein de l'om à l'un de
ses hauts responsables a affirmé mardi
qu'il existe bien un lien entre la
formation de caillots sanguins constatée
ces dernières semaines et le vaccin nous
cherchons à obtenir un tableau précis de
ce qui se passe à définir de manière
précise ce syndrome dû au vaccin
parmi les personnes vaccinées il ya un
nombre de cas de thrombose cérébrale
chez les personnes jeunes supérieur à ce
à quoi nous nous attendrions ce qui
cause cette réaction cependant nous ne
le savons pas encore pour résumer dans
les prochaines heures
nous dirons qu'il y a un lien mais nous
devons encore comprendre comment cela se
produit dans la foulée le m à mesurer
ses propos
l' agence européenne déclare être
toujours en train d'évaluer si le sérum
peut être lié à la formation de
thrombose signalé au royaume uni en
allemagne ou encore en france alors que
le vaccin d'astrazeneca a été suspendue
dans plusieurs pays
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
estimé que le rapport risques bénéfices
continuent de peser largement en faveur
de l'utilisation du vaccin mais en
france deux familles ont déjà porté
plainte contre x pour homicide
involontaire après la mort d'un homme de
63 ans et d'une femme de 38 ans tous
deux vacciner à l'astra zeneca de son
côté le parquet de nantes a ouvert une
enquête préliminaire suite au décès d'un
étudiant en médecine